so
the first story that we had was a poll
from convention of states and trafalgar
group showing that independent
republican voters are furious over the
raid on trump and are heavily motivated
now to actually come out and vote in the
midterms you got to wonder with news
like that if the fbi was just trying to
make sure republicans won
because
three months out from a midterm election
they raid the former president that's
going to light up independence and
republicans like crazy but then uh as
we're getting the show ready we there
there was a breaking story actually from
a couple hours ago from penn live the
fbi has subpoenaed several pa republican
lawmakers
this is this is crazy expansion
i don't know what it is they're trying
to do
what they're trying to get but i wonder
if this might turn into some kind of
october surprise where they do all of
these things now sure it riles up
republicans but then come october they
issue some some criminal uh indictments
on a bunch of individuals and say aha
look in an attempt to smear republicans
i don't know for sure
so we'll talk about that and then we got
some
ridiculous stories i guess rosita's been
canceled
sesame street or whatever character for
being racist
so we'll talk about that in censorship
before we get started my friends head
over to timcast.com and become a member
to support our work and you will get
access to exclusive uncensored shows
from tim cast irl we're gonna have one
up for you tonight at 11 pm we do that
monday through thursday and our new show
tales from the inverted world plus i
believe uh the cass castle vlog is
obviously delayed again because we're
trying to really relaunch things and
make something special for y'all so
that'll be a new show coming out
probably next week but we want to make
sure we do it right when we start and
then we're going to have new episodes
every week plus we've got a couple
documentaries in the works it's going to
be really awesome we have the gun
control documentary is currently
underway
we are
i shouldn't say too much yet but we're
working with someone you guys probably
already figured out what we're doing so
um we'll mention that when we can so
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
joining us today to talk about this and
so much more is naomi wolfe
thank you so much for having me on
do you want to introduce yourself for
those who aren't familiar with you sure
um i'm naomi wolfe i'm um the author of
eight non-fiction books usually about
women's issues or civil liberties um
they were all bestsellers i'm glad to
say um i have a new book out called the
end of i'm sorry that was my last book
my new book is called um which is a
sequel to it is called the bodies of
others the new authoritarians covid19
and the war against the human
i am the mother of two and a stepmom of
two
wife of a veteran um and
i'm also ceo of a tech company called
daily clout dot io civic tech company
yeah and it's its goal is to make
democracy easier for everyone to use i
know a lot of people were already
chatting they're familiar with they're
familiar with you mostly through
feminism and through you know past
instances where you've done interviews
and i'm sure many people
you know their their attitude is like
you know oh man this is going to be a
debate or something but and maybe but i
think it's fascinating is that you came
out heavily against vaccine mandates and
restrictions you've been canceled and
banned over the over these stances which
i think most of the people who watch the
show probably agree with you on so i
appreciate you coming i think it's going
to be a really interesting conversation
thank you well i'm so grateful to have
it right on we also have hannah claire
bremelo joining us hi i'm hannah claire
i'm a writer for timcast.com
hi everyone
what's up sorry i guess i need a longer
intro i don't know there you go yeah
yeah you got to have a uh you got to
promote something when you come on the
show that's what people like okay i
encourage you all to visit timcast.com
it's a really great news site that's
fantastic i personally love it
well i'm not gonna i'll promote
dailycloud.io because we were talking
about it before the show it sounds
pretty fascinating um that you're gonna
make it easier for people to read and
vote and talk about bills before they go
to congress yeah or that pro i love that
so maybe get that into that later but hi
everyone i'm here to stay
ian is here for sure and i am as well in
the corner i'm delighted to have naomi
i'm excited to learn about what all we
have in common i think it will surprise
all of us thank you i think it's
supposed to thunderstorm too that'll be
fun just so that you know hopefully
anybody who works here is listening just
in case yeah
so uh put out a word yeah you know
because the power flickers and stuff
that's what happens when you live in the
world yeah let's jump into this first
story so as we're getting ready to uh
put the show together we i caught this
story it was published just around 6 p.m
fbi delivers subpoenas to several pa
republican lawmakers sources say
at least some of the individuals
receiving subpoenas were told they were
not targets of an investigation
according to at least six sources
reached by pennlive but that they may
have information of interest to the fbi
all of the sources have been briefed on
the investigative moves in some way but
demanded anonymity in order to discuss
them the information being requested
centered around u.s rep scott perry and
the efforts to seek alternate electors
as part of former president donald
trump's efforts to remain in office
after the 2020 election several sources
say said the washington post on
wednesday citing a source for me with
the probe also reported perry's cell
phone was seized tuesday as part of the
justice department's criminal
investigation into the use of fake
electors to try to overturn president
biden's victory the post source also
spoke on the condition of anonymity
spokespersons for the pennsylvania house
and senate republican leaders did not
confirm whether any of their caucus
members received a subpoena quote i am
unaware of any fbi presence in the
capitol or leader benninghoff's office
yesterday
to the extent house members or my staff
may have contact may have been contact
contacted by the fbi we would not
comment on a potential or ongoing
investigation
so
there's a there's a few simple points to
make and the first one i'm going to say
is i don't trust the fbi i don't trust
the doj i don't trust the federal
government
that being said
they're they're trying to claim
that by having alternate electors it's
some kind of fraud but if you go back to
i think it was 1968 correct with my
wrong during it was nixon and kennedy
was it 68 maybe i'm wrong i don't know
you want to check me that was
there was a dispute in hawaii
and hawaii sent an alternate slate of
electors which nixon as the vice
president decided to use even though
they weren't the certified electors
what's in 1960 next 66 and kennedy yeah
and next okay so 60. yeah why
68 um
now what happens is you have this uh
contentious legal battle in 2020 a bunch
of republicans
you know the the electors for the
republican side which were not the
certified electors for the state did
fill out these forms and sentiment
anyway now they're acting as though that
was a criminal action or fraud or
something perhaps they're going to use
that as a means to stop donald trump
from being from being able to run again
or it's just part of the bigger just go
after trump by all means or whatever do
you think this is similar to the nevada
they called them fake electors but
alternate electors that were subpoenaed
by the general six committee hey it's
all the same thing
this is so interesting to me because it
just looks like the media is writing
history in real time like they want us
to believe this is insane it's never
happened before but it happened in 1960
there's nothing crazy about this they're
just trying to make it up as they go
along i do think the whole thing's crazy
it's a little weird yeah so we had i
think it was 46 states or something that
were involved in a lawsuit do you
remember this in in 2020
the texas filed a lawsuit against i
think pennsylvania maybe pennsylvania
and then it expanded into like 46 states
where you had like 24 suing 20 you know
assuming these these like it was
michigan wisconsin pennsylvania and then
you had the other 22 in defense of those
states
and the supreme court which has original
jurisdiction to hear lawsuits between
states rejected it they said no outright
so we never got resolution on these
arguments and this is leading
now
we're heading to the point where the fbi
has raided the home of the former
president right told them their lawyer
could not be present while they were
enacting the search
broke the padlock off the room that they
requested be there god i got an
interesting email earlier
and i'll call it unconfirmed
in my morning segment i was talking
about there's a report from uh ken i
think it's kendall any i could be wrong
he was on nbc
and he said a few months ago the fbi
requested a padlock be placed on this
room at mar-a-lago which had these
documents they then went in and broke
the padlock they requested
that's a simple way to put it if you
think the fbi is one guy but the fbi's
not one guy it's not a monolith right so
i got contacted by someone alleging that
they were a former uh fbi agent and they
said
you know
they didn't tell me anything crazy they
just said you're right
the fbi is a bunch of different offices
it's not monolithic there is leadership
but often there
you know there's like senior leadership
that will take actions in one direction
without one other office knowing so my
assessment was
one group of on the on the board on the
level fbi agents say okay we know what
you got here it's fine just padlock it
in case
this other group of agents gets a
warrant signed off by an epstein judge
or a former epstein uh defense attorney
yeah and then goes in and smashes the
padlock and
sees his documents or something like
that allegedly
yeah so uh banana republic collapse
united states um i'll throw it to my
panel my
one of the most wild things i read
coming out of all of that was andrew
cuomo who's like the doj should really
explain what's going on otherwise it's
going to start to look like the january
6 committee is not credible
andrew cuomo the disgraced ex-governor
of new york i mean if anyone really can
recognize when something is corrupt i
like i would assume someone who has been
asked to leave office would be a good
good judge of character there yeah
i mean
should i just jump right in and yeah
what do you think right yeah
you know when i was a political
consultant
to the
vice president in 2000 also a contested
election outcome in which no one was
criminalized for asking questions about
the outcome i mean this is really
haunting me but also i advised
the clinton re-election campaign and
what i learned as a political consultant
is to read events backwards in other
words what's happening like what's the
what's the outcome like let's leave the
story alone because what you learn as a
consultant is that at that level the
guys in the room choose the outcome and
and then they go to the message guys
down the hall and ask the message guys
to come up with a story to get the
american people to accept the outcome
the goal and often the story has nothing
to do with a goal so i'd encourage you
almost like
don't pay that much attention to what
you're being told about the reasons that
lawmakers who are republican are being
subpoenaed or that the president of the
united states has
you know 30
people bursting into his private home
and seizing his materials and look at
everyone else project veritas is related
to this steve bannon having a swat team
going into his private home is related
to this i mean what the you know leaving
the stories aside the overall chess
board is the criminalization of being a
republican
you know and do you ever think you'd say
that
i mean yeah i wrote this book the end of
america in 2008 warning that we were
hurtling toward you know that there are
10 steps tyrants always take to close
down an open society and that step 10 is
where we're at now i didn't know we'd
get here so fast i thought we'd headed
off at the pass because we're you know
able to
cherish our republic but clearly we're
not doing that but yeah so the the
outcome is you're exactly right to worry
about timing tim because
you know these are dangerous months and
i've been saying this for months you
know leading up to these months you what
what are we in now august september
october november right it's going to get
crazy and the goal is to have things so
unstable so scary
chilling everywhere you know shocking
images people's homes being broken open
people being led away in handcuffs peter
navarro in leg chains right this is all
part of the the drama the spectacle of
what what other countries like like
russia and china understand is
tenderizing an enemy so the american
people are being tenderized right now
and the goal is to completely
incapacitate the republican leadership
to scare journalists and critics like
you and me because that's part of it and
i'll just say me i'm scared
and and also to um to tie up the
leadership like bannon and trump in so
many legal problems and hassles that
they are not able to uh to pose a threat
to the outcomes that are already foreign
and alex jones and alex jones absolutely
he's not you know jones was so massively
influential in 2014-1516
they they
they found a way to get him off all
these platforms and alex jones for all
the criticisms that i think he deserves
he got wiped off of the internet back to
back all the same time right you know so
so maybe you can call it a cascade
effect but i think powerful interests
were like this is a guy who's rallying
people with a massive platform this
can't be allowed right
i guess i guess my question for you when
you wrote the book in 2008 did you think
it was going to be republicans who would
turn out to be the victims of this
that's such a painful question
i mean right
right at the time um it was republicans
doing the bad things as mitt romney and
like john mccain
oh no worse it was dick cheney i mean it
was guantanamo it was you know the
global war on terror that was the
terrifying internal external threat
invocation that's step one of the ten
steps to fascism now it's a virus um but
to be fair liz cheney's still here and
she's leading the charge yeah you know
well thank goodness
wyoming is so happy
i guess what i said then i mean i
remember this my people are so dumb um
who are your people in this the former
liberal i mean i'm a i'm a liberal by
you know classical liberal all my life
registered democrat all my life
my former people my former tribe of the
left are very short-sighted and they're
they're cheering about you know project
veritas who's in trouble donald trump is
in trouble it's like cheering the rope
that is going to hang them
metaphorically you know and they're not
reading history but the reason i say
this is that in 2008 i remember everyone
around me going we just need to get
obama in and then there will be no more
tyranny and i'm like are you insane are
you insane these things of you know
shutting down democracies the left and
the right both do it and and during the
obama years i was one of like
five people on the left including glenn
greenwald who were like you know what
he's drowning americans guantanamo is
still open it's growing you know all of
these promises are not being kept um so
i didn't expect it would be republicans
being hunted but i'm not surprised that
that has come about i was fairly young
in 2008 i voted for obama and uh i was
skeptical but i kept hearing from all
these people saying like this guy's
different he's not the same part of the
machine he's an outsider and you know he
came from community organizing and i was
like i don't know sure whatever i'll
vote for the guy and then one of the
first things he did was he blew up some
kids right was i think it was like
literally within a few days a drone
strike in pakistan killed hillary uh hit
a village and then i was like wait a
minute we were protesting the war and
this guy just did this thing then when
2012 came around i was just like yeah
right you're not going to get me to vote
for this guy again and now we've got uh
i i love bringing it up because of how
important it is the the extrajudicial
assassinations carried out by the obama
administration this is why i was so
adamantly opposed to joe biden i ended
up voting for trump i didn't vote for
him in 2016 but in 2020 i was like
you're not giving me biden you know
obama 2.0 or whatever and and it ended
up ended up happening so
well you've had quite a journey i mean
how do people your former friends feel
about that
former friends right you know uh well
interestingly
my real friends that i mostly grew up
with only a few of them have lost their
minds but there have been some weird
circumstances but
surprisingly like i have a friend who's
deeply woke
still a really good friend and just like
we don't talk about it yeah it's it's
kind of weird and it comes up sometimes
and you can feel tensions rising and
then it's just like let's talk about
horror movies yeah
but i'm glad that can happen yeah but
but i do think
you know for for someone like this a
friend of mine they're not overtly
political it's you know you're
mentioning the your former liberal you
know associates or cohorts or whatever
they're just not paying attention and
they're passively absorbing what they're
being told and assuming it's true yeah
i can't yeah i should say i feel like
with my friends
liberal or even there are conservatives
like this too they're
a lot of them aren't inherently
political and there are a couple issues
that matter to them and so they'll buy
the whole ticket even though they can't
see like you're saying that these are
ultimately interwoven issues they can't
see what their decisions will lead to in
the domino effect i gotta just jump
right to abortion
right uh the democrats recently tried to
pass a bill that would that would allow
abortion up to nine months oh god it
didn't it so it was cleverly worded
that um
in the instance where the mother's
health was in jeopardy an abortion could
be carried out post to viability right
and so i my response we had a
progressive on was very simple like okay
i hear you
if the baby is viable why abort it yeah
why not just deliver it did this person
actually support
that bill and and and beyond this
individual told us it's the woman's
choice no matter what up to the point of
birth yeah and my position
i grew up in chicago i grew up with a
liberal family and we were always like
yeah maybe like the first trimester
pre-viability we understand after that
you're you're in dangerous territory now
the left is just wholesale like whenever
whatever i think larry otter was on the
show and saying that it's the health of
the mother as well so it could be like
if she's gonna suffer depression then
maybe she can terminate an eight and a
half month old fetus
it's not just about the life of the
mother it's about the health of the
mother which is like vague but
just to bring it up you know you as uh i
guess former you could you consider
yourself a former liberal you're still
liberal no i'm i'm a classical liberal i
you know me and three other people yeah
yeah or politically homeless is
totally a political refugee absolutely
so so you're obviously not in favor of
abortion up to nine months no i am not
yeah it's it's crazy what the left has
become
that they would call us right wing
you're raising questions about that it's
crazy it's insane i mean what really
scares me about this is the kind what
i'm seeing on the left
is this kind of um entrainment almost
intellectually where
if
the thing is support ukraine you can't
ask any questions about you know
ukraine's abusiveness to the rule of law
if the thing is abortion
and under any circumstances no matter
how crazy the bill is no matter how
extreme how sadistic how abusive how i
would say anti-woman and anti-baby it is
to you know extend the abortion
capability into the second month into
the i'm sorry second trimester third
trimester
if that's the thing
it just seems to be plugged into
people's minds on the right and they
just kind of follow like lemmings like
with no critical thinking they can't
demur
and there are a lot of interesting
reasons for that but i do think on the
left um critical debate is no longer
possible and
and it's so important to distinguish
themselves from
from like trump lovers or whatever they
call anyone who disagrees with them um
and and that's really scary to me
because if you look at history it's
people in that mind state that go along
with genocide and look what they went
along with and go along with the former
left people i know and love who would
never discriminate against a gay couple
or a lesbian couple never discriminate
on the basis of race embraced a
discrimination society that was just
like a jim crow two-tier
discrimination society when did you when
did you start uh anti-i like i can't
i couldn't walk into a building in new
york city because i'm not vaccinated
and people i i know and love who are
right on were completely fine with
treating unvaccinated people legally and
in every other way as others who are
less than oh yeah like rats or something
i've heard that before but to to to play
uh to to add to your point we had in
dearborn michigan the non-poc and the
poc digital cafes the university of
michigan in seattle they have what yeah
have you seen oh yeah that's illegal yes
yeah there was uh who was it was it uh
was it um was it michael uh cypher just
the other day mentioning yelp i think he
said that was offering a grant based on
race yeah i don't know yeah but like
it's super easy
there were uh african-american students
at nyu that were asking for their own
dorm that's segregation but they were
like no it's better for us yup yup so uh
you you've you've been in politics way
longer than i have when did you start
noticing this this shift happening in
the left losing their minds ah that's
tough i mean
i guess in the last
four or five years i would see positions
that
were out there on the left and i would
just dismiss them because i i thought
that's nonsense no one i know really
would believe that or do that um like
the whole like the first time i remember
hearing the phrase dead white men and
that culture created by dead white men
or the phrase toxic masculinity i would
just think well that's ridiculous those
are ridiculous concepts you know
why
how can you possibly take seriously
dismissing great works of art
masterpieces our whole cultural heritage
because of the gender and race of the
person who did it that's racism and
that's sexism obviously and it's also
self-destructive and
as a mom of a man and a stepmom of a
11 year old future man
i really you know object to this phrase
toxic masculinity or nonsensical
statements about
like male sexuality heterosexuality
being innately you know abusive or
exploitive um those are very damaging
things to say to young men and boys and
they're they're also just destructive
because it doesn't have to be that way
and it you know where's love and wears
you know this ideal of people finding
each other if they happen to be
heterosexual that shouldn't be any you
know less valid than any other sexuality
that people want to be
um
so
but i didn't take those seriously but
once
like victory's so bad for us on the left
it's so toxic for us to win because once
we won
um you know the presidency and the house
it was like
a scary marxist flood that was like
latent and dormant very much influenced
by the ccp i am
i am convinced and the world economic
forum and other bad actors bill and
melinda gates foundation but this this
latent marxist stalinist
aggressive
violent coercive flood of nonsense just
um
erupted and and now people on the left
have no
qualms about being
as as coercive and oppressive as they
want to be i like posting on uh i got a
lot of occupy wall street people who
follow me and i like posting on
they'll post things like trump has been
raided by the feds they'll laugh with
smiley faces and i'll be like my
response to them is always i'm glad that
you finally came around to supporting
the feds in the federal government right
it took you a long time to realize they
were the good guys absolutely and then
their response was like well i mean
it's different hey keep cheering them on
man keep cheering them on because we
know where this is when did they stop
having like the kantian imperative of it
it has to be consistent if you don't
want them to shut you down and censor
you you can't censor project veritas you
can't if you don't want them to come for
your president you can't go for their
president like why don't they see that
would you say that they feel like they
have the moral high ground the total
things that
project veritas are doing while they may
be structurally similar you know it's
another form of censorship to oppress
them it's worth oppressing because they
are promoting
the wrong things well you're a thousand
percent right um and it's
again super scary because on the left
there's been this mission creep of
language increasing you know what i'm
going to say right yeah increasingly
identifying thoughts as violence or
speech as incitement um
such that it it in january 6 was a big
part of this like
such that i think the left really feels
like
the people who disagree with him are so
dangerous and all white supremacists and
you know the things they think are so
innately violent we have to cut it off
before the thought even gets there we
can't expose any of this material to
anyone because they might
indoctrinate someone else aka get them
to think about an issue in a way that we
don't believe in absolutely and sorry oh
is the fear that if trump becomes
president he's going to make america
like america is he going to he's going
to make it totalitarian because you
they're using the fbi to kick down doors
right now like what are they afraid is
going to happen
i mean they're afraid someone's going to
kick their door down yeah they're both
from new york brothers so we both the
northeast everywhere right right okay so
truly the left believes and i used to
believe a lot of this i really did
because they lie to us legacy media lies
to us and and liberal media lies to us
um i'm not saying the right is
perfect or doesn't distort but these are
the kinds of things the left truly
believes that if trump were elected or
there was another right wing or
conservative president uh it would be
like margaret atwood's um handmaid's
one reference we can't get over as a
society right harry potter right um and
and and that uh that every conservative
is racist every conservative want is is
homophobic um and that it would be
kind of a bible-based reactionary
america in which religious minorities
would be quashed in which um there would
be no freedom to love
there would be a fossil fuel
orgy leading to the demise of the planet
in a matter of weeks is this fair i mean
is there more you want to add that
totally that women would be forced to
conceive and raise children you know
that they didn't want or that they
couldn't take care of
and you know there's some there's some
truth to these concerns but in
functioning civil society you talk these
things out and you create policies that
you know meet in the middle i i don't
believe them because in any sys like
they may actually have broken world
views that i can believe but this idea
that the right is simultaneously
advancing fascism while trying to give
you guns makes no sense
like quick everybody has any go
i argued that the second amendment does
cover nuclear weapons not that it should
cover nuclear weapons but during the
time of the founding fathers you could
have a private tier you could have a
frigate you could have grape shot you
could have full you know a plethora of
cannons the same armaments the
government had that that never changed
so my my point was
perhaps people would agree you should
not allow this and we would need to make
that amendment they all got really angry
that i'd bring it up my my point here is
why were they angry if you don't mind my
ass well they called me like a wing nut
arguing that people should have new
people
sounds terrible they didn't misinterpret
it media matters
you said people should have their
weapons according to the second
amendment they thought he meant i think
morally people should have nuclear
weapon where he was saying no legally
according to the rule right now people
should be able but but just my point
right now is
i i'll tell you i'll tell you a story i
was in uh berkeley during the battle for
berkeley when all the antivo were
fighting the trump supporters and i
actually got to talk to an antifa guy
after everything was calming down
because i was just standing there like
you know and this guy said i asked this
antifa guy like what happened
and he said they came up and they
punched my friend and then we started
talking and he told me that he brought a
knife that he was going to defend
himself and then he said and i asked him
why and he said because these are
fascists man they want to they want to
kill people and i said you think all of
those people in that park are fascists
right there and he's like yeah dude
they're all fascists and i said do you
think that those people in that park
want to defend the second amendment and
he was like well yeah of course the
right always talking about guns and i
was like
do you think that they would then care
if you had guns like no i'm like so you
think they're fascists but they want you
to have guns right and he was like oh
and i'm like yeah i i don't get your
logic there's no logic there it's just
tribalism right
it is but also a horrible thing has
happened in the last 10 or 15 years in
america in which these two groups never
get to talk to each other and i think
social media has really escalated that
because the algorithm makes sure that
you only
you know you're fed further and further
to one side of the spectrum or the other
there is like you can see a youtube
video with someone you don't agree with
and back in the day you could make a
video response and we had incredible
conversations in 2007
google's taking away the video response
mechanic for oddly but wow but i want to
respond i mean the meme is that ben
shapiro is screaming debate me
like people on the right are adamantly
saying come have the conversation i mean
we had larry elder on this show and he
was talking about how he's invited all
of these people and they won't come and
talk to him we i mean we talked about
this on the way up tim you know i run
into this as as an editor of of daily
cloud and it breaks my heart we on the
left or we liberals all say we're
supposed to be the ones who believe in
free speech remember the free speech
movement in berkeley that was led by the
left mario salvo savio was on the left
um we're supposed to believe in um you
know not believe in censorship uh alan
ginsberg you know like
lady chatterley's lover these are
liberals but now i
you know i'll have people will send me
right leaning op-eds and i'll reach out
to all of my remaining liberal contacts
or just you know put out the word we go
to neral and say will you please tell us
you know why this pro-life op-ed is
wrong write your own op-ed and they
won't do it or we'll go to the green um
advocates and say tell us why this
pro-fossil fuel op-ed is wrong and they
won't do it they'll just say you
shouldn't run that material i'm not
going to be appearing a a document where
other people who hold these views appear
i'll give a shout out to jacobin are you
familiar with jackman magazine i am
they're pro free speech good for them
i've consistently seen articles from
them where they they say outright we
should not tolerate the censorship and
things like that and i'm like hey man
look i don't gotta agree with the
socialists if we agree on respecting
each other's right to speak then i'll
take what i can get right now you've got
following the fbi raids a bunch of mtg
martial taylor green
i guess she's selling merch i'm not
entirely sure but it says like defund
the fbi
crowder has called for something similar
the washington post ran a story saying
the right now wants to defund law
enforcement and leftists are laughing
and i'm like bro this was your position
shouldn't you be cheering shouldn't you
be like we're heading
yeah yeah what happened what happened is
that their opponents are getting the
punishment yeah they enjoy it another
problem is that like censorship's
important in the right context you don't
want to allow people to make imminent
threats of violence it's illegal under
the first amendment it's already illegal
yeah and it's illegal as a form of
censorship right and pictures of
children yeah stuff like that you censor
that sense but corporations now are in
control of the public square with
alphabet and and meta and things like
that where they can more or less
terminate your access to the masses um
and people the law has yet to catch up
to that i don't think that
private companies should be overriding
the first amendment in the united states
so i i advocate that we free the
software code of large social networks
so that other people can spin up
networks that can interoperate with them
and it will
seize the means of production free the
means of production
similar let's jump to this this story
here this one they want uh this is the
story we originally going to lead with
this is from conventionofstates.com
large majority of independents
republicans believe trump's political
enemies are behind the fbi raid and are
now more likely to vote in 2022 midterms
this is uh from trafalgar group in the
convention of states they say 83 of
republicans 72 of independents now more
likely to vote i mean that's really good
news if you want republicans to win
that's the best get out the vote effort
the government's ever had right but but
right and so there's a few points to be
made the first thing i want to say is
there's no guarantee republicans winning
does anything for anybody granted seeing
more like america first style
politicians who are just like more like
ron paul like just know we're gonna
we're send government authority and
things like that i can accept as
it's better in my opinion that many of
these candidates win then the democrats
retain control and steam steam roll
through things but i have to wonder
was the fb
if there's no political motivation in
what the fbi is doing
then
they don't care that this is riling up
independent voters or republican voters
unless
there is political motivation which i
think most people believe there is
so my assumption now is october surprise
that in about two and a half months
these raids and subpoenas the reason
they're doing it now is so they can have
the filings done they can have the
judge's signatures and then come the end
of october it's bam criminal indictment
criminal indictment accusation
accusation the entirety of the of the
corporate press will be dominated with
republican arrested republican arrested
so they don't lose the midterms how else
do they expect
with massive inflation
with horrible gas prices i know they've
come down quite a bit bravo but they're
still really high the misery index is so
high and the historical trends democrats
should get wiped out in the midterms
unless they can pull some insane october
surprise and make a bunch of arrests
maybe maybe not but that's kind of what
it feels like to me here huh
i feel like i'd go one step further to
say
the ultimate goal to what you're talking
about before was
they want to try and prevent trump from
running again and if they
destroy the credibility of anyone who is
kind of positioned as an ally to him as
someone who has supported him
not just like he's a bad guy we don't
like it but he's literally on trial he's
in jail they're hoping to win enough
support
to make it seem like it's an absolute
non-starter we cannot elect donald trump
i don't think they have a better
candidate i don't think joe biden will
be able to run again so really what
they're trying to do is knock the
republican
republicans most likely most likely
chess piece off the table to try and get
ahead of whatever's going to happen next
because they are in a weak position
themselves larry elder said it has to be
kamala harris
because because uh democrats are uh
dependent upon the black vote and that
if they abandon kamala harris for
someone else it's going to be deeply
hurtful to the black community she's not
competent but that's that's very deeply
unpopular i don't i don't know if i
necessarily agree but far be it for me
to claim to know better than than larry
aldridge uh cortez i mean it's almost
like is she actually going to run for
president that'd be cool i hope she said
it'd be someone else
we talked about before a trump aoc
debate oh yes great great so i i got i
got i got i got a couple angry emails
from people they're like how dare you
say you would like to see aoc run for
president i'm like yeah i think it'd be
hilarious i mean fantastic that's way
better than what the democratic
governors association is doing to their
voters right they're pouring money into
racist to get the quote-unquote most
extreme candidate elected so they can
theoretically beat them in the midterm
but but think about that the democrats
have been funding we know this the maga
candidates the trump supporting
candidates or they've been funding their
messages really yeah yes oh my gosh so
uh that's weird it was uh
the idea is that trump candidates cannot
win in a general election wow so when
you put them in driving everything to
the extremes there was i mean but my
point here is real quick
consider that now consider what the fbi
is doing
seems to make a bit more sense
they fund a bunch of these ultra maga
candidates then the fbi starts going
after trump and his inner circle to
taint the well and poison these
candidates so when they when they make a
criminal indictment of someone in the
trump circle or trump himself they can
say the criminal man himself endorsed
this candidate don't vote for him right
oh my god
oh so ugly i mean there's also the
possibility that
um if they funded
maga candidates which is like smarter
than i am used to democrats being but
they they also would know if there's any
dirty linen because they have to do
opposition research right you know and
they save it for october and they save
it for october for sure but i think it
could be even worse i think that they
there's an element of trying to provoke
um republicans especially trump
supporters i think they're going to be
very shocking images we're going to see
you know with and god forbid i hope i'm
wrong and i have to be nonpartisan so
i'm saying this very carefully but um i
think we're going to see images of like
the president in handcuffs or the
president in a perp walk or the
president uh behind bars or some kind of
highly iconic image um and
and i think that the goal is to provoke
and we're going to get and i'm seeing it
already a lot of like social media like
um whipping people's emotions up
instigators infiltrators and violence
and that's and that will be a
justification for a crackdown state of
emergency you can't vote in person you
have to vote by mail and then of course
we know the vulnerabilities with them
yeah trouble trust me to count your
votes for you you guys everyone give me
a piece of paper i'll tell you what this
is
what uh yeah i mean that's that's the
argument uh i completely agree with ian
that we have a proprietary company we
have a company with proprietary software
code in how our voting voting is handled
they should be public i totally agree i
also think people should photograph
their vote and we've offered at daily
cloud you can send it to us and we'll
create a you know locked third party
kind of platform where you can mirror
your vote and and at least there will be
a record of it what are your thoughts on
january 6th
a lot of them are
i mean
it's a very difficult thing to answer
partly because speech about january 6th
is being criminalized
i
think i will just say that
you know the rule of law is incredibly
important both
you know to protect
our institutions and also to protect the
rights of people who are accused of
crimes and the other thing i will say is
that very generally america has a long
history of infiltrators and provocateurs
yep i remember watching a video a long
time ago i was out of canada where it
was some leftist protest and there were
three guys that were wearing what was
very obviously a uniform
like they were undercover cops and they
were like this is what protesters wear
put on a hoodie jeans and boots and then
everyone's like those three guys dressed
the exact same and started throwing
bottles right you know so we hear a lot
of stories like that there was that
story out of i think it was minnesota
where a guy shows up and smashes out
windows and then leaves i don't know
exactly what happened with that but i
guess the concern now is
you know with ray apps i'm sure you're
familiar with the ray up saga here's a
guy on camera telling people to go in
the building and now the media is
calling him a victim
so you got
there was a report yesterday
that uh armed protesters were going to
show up to mar-a-lago and everyone
immediately says feds because no no the
right doesn't protest they they almost
never go outside and and what
well they go outside but not to protest
really no i mean for protests really
yeah so so uh but it's but it's obvious
if you live in a big city where it's
predominantly liberal it's really easy
to walk outside and see other people who
agree with you in march right if you
live in a rural area you could be
you know
between 100 yards and
and and
and
10 miles from the nearest person
not easy to organize that protest and
then where do you protest in cities it's
easy to walk from like town hall to like
the police station yeah but if you live
in a big unincorporated area what where
are you going to protest there's like
one to drive the dc right what we end up
seeing is
protests overwhelmingly tend to be left
or liberal
rarely are they right-wing or
conservative though they do happen
so when you get people showing up armed
and doing these right-wing protests
people just kind of roll their eyes like
what is going on you know yeah i mean to
be fair there were a lot of real people
really in of course dc to support the
president well
right that's their right to show up in
dc to support the president i think uh
what was it like 200 000 some odd people
showed up to and then it was like 800 at
the capitol
so they they demonize every single
person who was in dc to see trump speak
conflating
watching a man talk with storming into a
building that's the really scary and and
i must add they conflate the people who
stormed in the building with those who
were let in by on the other side of the
building it was a huge city block that
building and the people on one side were
breaking stuff the other people were
being led in by police and they've
threw them all in detention no no no let
those people out man it's time for a
great pardon i don't care any of them
joe biden dealings in ukraine he's
sending his son on the board of an
energy company in ukraine pardon him i
don't want i'm done i'm done with going
after people right now because if we try
and persecute each other it's just going
to be passing the football back and
forth and back ian it's not persecution
it's justice i mean that our
our system calls for a trial by jury a
trial by one's peers people have to be
accountable for what they've done
we've supported the war machine for too
long we're all culpable
yeah but hunter biden
look i'll put it this way
the january 6 defendants who have been
locked up in like solitary that
shouldn't be happening i mean they can
be they can be under house arrest not
going anywhere did you see what uh
walkaway did at cpac they had like a
cage with someone listening to testimony
the whole time it was brilliant
you know so he was yeah i think he was
actually convicted you know yeah we've
done illness as americans yes but look
look you can you can put hunter bite on
trial we don't gotta throw them in
solitary you can put the january six
writers on trial you don't got to put
them in solitary i would i would
absolutely respect them being like look
you guys were violent okay
house arrest until your your court date
and then you get charged uh
based on the crime you committed that
that's the reality of things hunter
biden yeah we want an investigation into
what he was doing in ukraine and in
china i want an investigation into what
joe biden's relationship was and all of
this sharing phone numbers sharing
emails i don't think we just say
you know you you you're free to go we're
done but i'll put it this way
i do agree and i stated before when it
comes to january 6 defendants a powerful
move would be to pardon all of them as a
sign of like we are seeking to end but
it's got to be nonpartisan i wouldn't
just pardon them you've got to pardon
more than that
but i don't need to be rude but i i so
disagree with both of you about this
um
god where do i start i mean
so i'm a survivor of a very bad
crime when i was a child and um the
people who suffer most when the rule of
law is degraded are women and children
and what i'm seeing right now with
defund the police and this movement is
just crazy to defund the police or to
let people um you know commit a certain
amount of shoplifting before they get
arrested as in santa monica where i just
was or just the degradation of the rule
of law the rise of crime is that it
hurts women and children most these i
don't want to like get drawn into
details of january 6th but i will say
again that content imperative
we have to be against violence we have
to be against people breaking the law
whether it's there whether it's the you
know mercenaries who are beating
truckers in canada that's violence
that's against the rule of law whether
it's people being locked in solitary
confinement that's against the geneva
conventions that's against the rule of
law like everywhere we need to restore
and make consistent the rule of law but
rather than abandon it i believe but
isn't there just a i i understand ian's
point i don't know if i would go so far
as to be like hunter biden's free to go
i maybe i'm a little biased when i say
the january 6 rioters or protesters but
the idea there is if we keep doing a tit
for tat it's going to escalate and keep
escalating like right you said the right
thing tim you said like there is a a
code of
penalties for
certain laws it's very cut and dried i
mean the law is a beautiful thing if you
really look at it
you know each person
not just there but anywhere across the
country antifa everybody you know
if they committed a crime the crime will
be in that state
book of crimes and there's a penal code
and they should
you know be tried and sentenced fairly
or tried and acquitted fairly um it's
the politicization that's so dangerous
i want to pardon these people because
one it acknowledges that they did commit
a crime right now no one's acknowledging
that biden committed a crime that i can
see in like in the position of power
james clapper said we did not wittingly
spy on americans with the prison program
we did he did he and his department
willingly spied on mary he he committed
perjury pardon him
acknowledge that he committed the crime
and pardoned him i i because right now
people are pretending like he didn't
commit a crime it's even worse but why
not um like investigate him and try him
because i don't want to hurt these
people i want to help the species what
you're describing seems like a political
prisoner swap to me we're just going to
keep trading back and forth like oh well
you this is the democratic so here's a
republican occasionally the green party
is going to be like what do we do to
like get someone like at the end of the
day it doesn't seem as productive it
sounds nice but i think ultimately
you're right like we have rule of law
for a reason we should indict people and
investigate them and bring them to a
fair trial but just saying well like we
think maybe you did something hunter but
we can't prove it but preemptively we'll
pardon you so we can pardon these other
people so later we can pardon him like
it just seems complicated and
unproductive to me
geez i mean the last two years have been
horribly unproductive it's like the
united states is an abusive relationship
beating each other and there's a whole
world out there that we're not paying
attention to because they're too busy
beating each other and i'm tired of it
so i totally agree with you about that
so i suppose the issue the divisiveness
yeah sorry you know we all sit here and
i think
we've actually started paying attention
all of us at some point and we learned
some interesting facts about what joe
biden was doing i see these memes on the
left where they're like donald trump
committed 34 crimes or something like
that and it's like all made up like
russia gate was fake ukraine gate was
fake and they just make these stories up
these people are convinced they're
seeking justice
not all of them some of them are just
tribal but a lot of them are like trump
committed crimes he has to be held
accountable and it's like what crimes
and they're like
he count documents did you see that
video luke rutkowski reposted today
where it's like someone protesting
outside of trump towers and they're like
we want him arrested for the provable
crimes they're like oh what provable
crimes and he's like
provable crime uh
i got to stop the interview right now
actually and it's the most awkward this
is freaking hilarious let me see i'm
just trying to fight going down down
down there right here
wait wait i always got to fix the audio
always always got to make sure the audio
is going to the people who are actually
watching the show i don't know what the
cause is this unprecedented to arrest a
former president for not turning into a
former president that had committed this
many provable criminal acts but what are
the provable criminal acts i guess
approval criminal acts well
i'm just i
i'm done talking is this unprecedented
can i just say on on the left i've had
people do that wave at me like i'm done
we're done we're done it's like where
did that come from when did that become
a thing you could just say there's like
there's these mine viruses around you'll
hear people talking right and they'll
say right after they say something as if
they're asking you if what they're
saying is correct wow it's like a call
it's like a tribal cult
recognition thing like up speak right i
hear rogan talking about it
yeah yeah and sometimes if you ask
someone something and then you make the
statement right like you're really
asking am i right that's a different
thing when you when you're just doing it
to get people to agree with you it's
this weird insecurity thing it started
in like the last two years watch for it
i i wanna i wanna play the game with
with this guy on this interview i want
to i want to play too so uh trump's
provable crimes um i don't think there
are any i can criticize him for during
because during his administration the
state department was advertising his
golf resorts or his resorts and he did
try to have uh i believe the g7 at trump
darrell those were like things i was
like hey whoa man you know
and then he backed when he was like well
i think i should do it but uh crimes
spare me the quid pro quo with ukraine
let's play a game should joe biden
be arrested for his provable crimes okay
well um
i want to be
sincere and get the nuance in the
context correct so i should say there
should be an investigation into joe
biden based on probable cause available
to the public notably that i believe it
was the council on foreign relations uh
meeting he was speaking publicly and
stated that uh he engaged in a quid pro
quo with ukraine uh with ukraine
something that we were told was illegal
so uh considering he admitted that he
said to the president of ukraine if you
don't if you don't uh uh fire the
prosecutor you're not getting a billion
dollars okay right there impeached and
or charged criminally and that that that
that extends way to uh to a whole bunch
of other issues like um hunter body was
on the board of barisma is this uh uh
absolute malfeasance where it wasn't
just a quid pro quo it was him
protecting his son's business interests
but then of course you know his son and
he shared emails and a phone number and
joe biden told the american people that
he didn't know anything about his son's
business dealings and then we learned
that actually there's a bunch of photos
of him with his son's business partners
and they they actually do know each
other and that uh hunter biden was flown
on air force two to china to negotiate a
private equity deal oh boy the list goes
on all of these things that have not yet
been investigated that we need to know
about and then the best part
joe biden engages in a quid pro quo with
ukraine
his son on the board of barisma
and he says you got to fire the
prosecutor and now as president
he is giving them billions of dollars
doesn't that sound a little weird to
anybody so if i was standing there and i
was like we got a arrest a sitting
president and someone said what crimes
did he commit i'd be like oh boy
i mean let me line them up for you the
crimes i mean everyone's got to read the
laptop from hell because that will shock
you with the abundance of criminality
that's thoroughly documented there um of
course you know he's never been tried
and convicted everyone's innocent until
proven guilty but there's as you say
massive massive evidence of of
wrongdoing at a very huge scale um it's
a huge national security problem and
this is what we really need to look at
hunter biden and by extension his whole
family the biden family kind of acts as
a criminal conglomerate uh in terms of
receiving funds collectively um
he received millions of dollars from a
high level
ccp related
alleged asset what wasn't it like five
million dollars in i don't remember the
exact amount but it was millions and
that doesn't happen without payback and
so now
sorry i believe it was a forgivable loan
right there you go i could be wrong i
could be like a donation right um but
look at our country again look backwards
reason backwards we our borders are open
um
our children are being propagandized our
our cultural norms and history is being
degraded are our you know
the the the the two groups as you were
saying ian are being set against each
other social media is deplatforming
critics of this dominant narrative that
is destroying the country um
you know images like worship is targeted
people are being arrested for holding
you know for convening their churches
and synagogues um so the ccp has a huge
role in all of this and this is how they
crush societies this is in their
playbook i think it's a vast
you know it is treason to accept money
from um to aid and abet our enemies and
i also read the description of what
impeachment is because that's what we do
at daily cloud and it takes a very low
bar for impeachment um high crimes and
misdemeanors is a pretty low bar so in
every way this is
you know the debt that the bidens have
to china is devastating our country um
and it is much more serious uh than than
the kinds of things that people have
raised in the past
i think it's been
oh the last sorry the
the president who you know even though i
didn't like him didn't vote for him um
had the fbi break into his house i uh
i'm glad you brought up the ccp i think
a lot about i don't like a boogeyman i
don't like creating a the arch enemy
that if we destroy them we will we will
win and everything will be okay that's
not how it works but they are
basically provoking an extension of the
opium wars it's been going on for 120
years and now they're running fentanyl
through mexico right up into the country
giving it back to the to the liberal
economic order what we did to them in
the 1890s we annihilated their their
populace with with opium
it's the liberal international economy
the lie the liberal international
economy
we're headed towards a new international
economy the night
yeah and it's going to be either i don't
know
i mean it's
how it happens are you familiar with
thucydides trap no
it's a concept um that we talk about
here ad nauseum
where uh whenever a dominant economic
power is about to be displaced by a
rising economic power
typically i should say i shouldn't say
whenever typically war breaks out oh
really so uh
i think i think it was like within the
past 500 years there have been 16
instances where something like this has
happened and 12 of them resulted in
major war wow so the argument is that
there are powerful interests in the
united states trying to prevent war
between the us and china by crippling
the united states and watching it
collapse before a war can break out so
the idea is if two powers reach a
similar level and they start competing
for who's going to dominate they
eventually just destabilize them
but if the dominant power is being
hacked away at the base and then it just
falls over
no war and told look at russia russia's
bad they're really bad yeah let's pay
more attention to that the russia
propaganda was freakish in 2015 when it
started that's so that's such a good
example of
how the people we know and i'm gonna see
me too got sucked into untruths i
believed that trump was a russian asset
because i read the new york times and i
watched cnn i believed it i believed
that he was in bed with the russians in
a way that was traitorous to our country
and now i know that all of that was
nonsense that the dossier was nonsense
but i didn't know that when did you
start because so there are people who
have the opportunity to look into this
and choose not to because they're still
part of they still believe in the
narrative so strongly what changed for
you well honestly
i'm always trying to be open-minded and
i didn't think that i was self-selecting
out information that would have
cut against it but when you're reading
the new york times
and watching cnn there's such a
repetition of
the washington times is a cult paper the
epic times is run by cult members the
you know they just dismiss every
conservative or independent or
libertarian outlet and so i was lucky i
married a libertarian and
libertarianism saves lives
no but i got exposed to where the lies
were um and other sources of information
and then i met a lot of people producing
the epic times or producing these other
news news sources they're very credible
journalists i think i think libertarians
and conservatives right now are doing
and you guys people like you are doing
some of the only credible journalism
remaining in america um but i guess
that's just to say i thoroughly believed
the lie that trump was a russian asset
what was the moment that it changed
um that is a good question
i will i think that the legacy media had
to recently like a few months ago step
back i don't remember the evidence that
emerged but they stepped back and said
oh sorry that was a lie and the dossier
wasn't true either um whoopsie yeah
but a lot of people were entrenched in
it for years and it's crazy that they
still won't let it go they still think
so
i think
i think it's actually quite simple
there's a bureaucratic state
civil servants who are appointed who are
not elected have an agenda they don't
care who the president is donald trump
is an arrogant blowhard so when he got
elected he just said excuse me no
and would not listen to what they they
insisted of him
and so they had to get him out of the
way
that's it i mean you look at his
administration so dramatically different
from the previous administrations right
in my lifetime i am 36 i've seen not
nearly as much as most people i think in
this well i shouldn't say most because i
don't know the demographics are but many
people in this country who are older
than me i think majority of the country
are older than me
maybe not i don't know but anyway my
point is
we get obama promising hope and change
it blows up kids
great then you get donald trump yeah he
does bad stuff like
missile strike in syria drone strikes
but no new wars pulling our troops out
of the middle east pulling our trips out
of syria trying to bring peace to the
middle east the abraham accords
negotiating the deal and i think it was
uh was it kosovo serbia or something
like that then you had um kim jong-un in
north korea he crossed into the dmz with
no security in a tremendous sign of
peace and leadership i mean it was
shocking to me that he did that they
could have just snatched him up and
taken the u.s president got one they
could have done a lot of stuff they
could have gripped his hand and held it
tight and said you're going to give us a
million dollars aren't you or or any
nonsense like that they just shook his
hand and then he left it was so
dramatically different his foreign
policy that i'd seen in such a long time
that it was very clearly in the way of
the war machine and the establishment
politics of this country yeah well i
think you're
completely right and just each one of
those so embarrassing but each one of
those huge achievements which i really
didn't credit until pretty recently um
was dismissed and derided by the legacy
media i i have to
stress this every opportunity i get when
donald trump went to the dmz the
demilitarized zone in the koreas
and he met with kim jong-un
the media said he was ponying up to
dictators and it was bad and he was
causing problems
the president of the united states i
remember that with no security detail
entered an enemy nation the war with
north korea is still
there's still a war the war did not end
and donald trump
crossed into the dm crossed into north
korea
shook hands with kim jong-un smiled and
waved for photos and then walked back
and i was just watching this shocked
like
whoa dude yeah i mean this is this this
o fish
blow hard reality tv guy
just risked his life right
in a sign of peace yeah and the media
just crapped all over him for it and i
was just like dude or or how about this
one
we lefties really hated the war in
afghanistan we really hated all those
wars that was the war machine
embarrassing to acknowledge president
trump actually brought our men and women
home you know he he scaled down the war
machine um no one gave him credit for
that on our side of it i guess what i
would say for the record though is as a
survivor of sexual assault the way he
spoke about women was catastrophic and i
could not bring myself to vote for
someone who is so dismissive about
sexual abuse it's that simple maybe that
was short-sighted of me but i kind of
shouldn't have to he should have had
advisers saying look just talk you know
apologize you know talk about it
compassionately say you've learned
whatever say you will try harder in the
future to not be you know horribly
abusive or describe women in horribly
abusive ways or describe sexual assault
this is when he's surprisingly this is
when he was like when you're famous they
let you you know yeah but even his
apology apology afterwards was very very
dismissive and i think that was a very
painful moment for you know the 33
percent of women who've been sexually
abused before they were 18 and the 17
percent of men um and and it was so hard
for me personally to get over that this
is what i think a lot of the really
die-hard trump supporters need to pay
attention to i agree there's there's a
lot of them that you know they'll say
like don't care it's funny it's awesome
i'm like i i can appreciate you think
it's funny and it's no problem like i i
hear trump and i laugh i i do appreciate
him being strong and aggressive i'm just
trying to convey
when i got into a car
i was going to glenn beck's studio and
the driver was a mexican immigrant who
came to america and became a citizen and
he said yeah man i love trump i just
wish you would stop saying that stuff
and i'm like
trump
does get a lot of people by being
aggressive but he could make some moves
that would retain that while also being
more appealing to run-of-the-mill people
who don't like that abrasive language i
remember one of the criticisms he got
all the time is that he wasn't
presidential enough he wasn't dignified
enough and
while that is a little bit different
from what the comments you're pointing
out i do think
in some ways some trump supporters
doubled down they like that he has these
rough edges and they like that he
doesn't sound the way obama sounded and
he doesn't sound the way career
politician biden sounds or sounded um i
don't like it man i can agree that like
his language around certain topics could
be better i
would not like to be the advisor to try
and corral trump into changing his
speech patterns
but i
i mean
i think
republican or conservative voters are
willing to
embrace flaws or at least uh pick and
choose flaws differently i think some of
the hang up with a lot of especially
young liberals that i know is that it
has to be absolute like there cannot be
any sins and that's ultimately
completely unreasonable who on the like
who among you has no sin right who are
they going to find from their side of
the aisle who has no sin to run for
office right i guess they don't have to
worry about they have to be hidden
enough right we have to not let them
surface right i think the left um has a
tendency to just scream lie to me please
what i mean by that is
they would prefer hillary clinton who
sounds correct i mean well let's be real
they didn't want hillary clinton either
everybody kind of groaned but they would
prefer barack obama's charming big old
smile lying to your face and blowing up
kids if it makes you feel good he says
plug your ears kids just plug your ears
everything's fine blow em up
whereas donald trump is the opposite i
loved it one of the greatest moments in
american presidential history was when
he's outside like in he's outside the
white house on the rose gun or whatever
and they ask him about saudi arabia and
he goes we're going to sell a bunch of
weapons to saudi arabia it's going to be
great for our economy and then all the
anti-war left was like he just said it
he said he just completely admitted what
they've never admitted that we're just
selling weapons to make money to bolster
our economy and trump just said it and i
was laughing the intercept called him
the most honest and dishonest president
of our lifetime wow or or or the united
states or whatever and i was just like
the funny thing is trump lies about
things that are dumb
like his ego stuff like no i didn't say
that you can't say that about me but
then he just openly admits all this
crazy stuff like we're going to keep the
troops in syria for the oil we like the
oil folks right there it was a good it's
like wow
but in retrospect i mean with all of
those flaws i mean it was it was peace
and prosperity did you vote for him in
2020 no
i did yeah but you know the
administration i voted for
colluded to silence me with oh yeah yeah
so it didn't work out that well let's
let's let's talk about media
manipulation and lies because uh you
know i want to say i'm shocked by the
story but i'm not shocked i my i i was i
mean i was kind of shocked okay the new
york post biden white house claims u.s
has zero inflation despite annual rate
remaining at 8.5 joe biden actually said
inflation last month zero percent and i
was like what inflation's at 8.5 it's
insane it's really really bad anyone
who's going you know trying to figure
out their finances right now is is
probably freaking out about this totally
you know what's scary
people are going to believe this and you
know this is the definition of a
recession the colloquial one is two per
two two consecutive quarters of negative
economic growth bill clinton said it and
you know 2001 or whatever and that viral
video from c from c-span people are
posting and uh the uk considers it that
and all of a sudden they're like no
actually that's not the definition of a
recession so uh we're changing it so
they're saying the technical definition
is actually quite different so now we're
not going to use that this is what
they're doing here
technically joe budden is correct axios
reports
inflation drops to zero in july due to
falling gas prices
and what that's not true it's eight
point five percent
i don't think you understand
do you ever play games with little kids
and they make up the rules and then we
start winning they change the rules yeah
right so what they're saying now is
month to month inflation was zero oh my
gosh right inflation is calculated on a
yearly basis and they decided to change
the way they calculate so they can
report and biden can lie and tell you
there's no inflation and every headline
can say no inflation zero inflation
under biden and they leave out all the
details because they know you're
scrolling you're not actually reading
the article the only the only thing they
need you to get to quote is the headline
educate me here eight point five percent
does that mean every year there's gonna
be an eight point five percent from this
time last year till to this month it has
increased by eight point five percent
and he's saying last month it was eight
point five percent this month it's still
eight point five percent zero exactly
[Laughter]
but it went up and then back down so
they're saying it didn't it's so amazing
but then the other issue is it's still
8.5
but food cost is still way up
gas is still way up all of these things
are way up but gas went down a little
bit so so the funny thing is
you also got to understand what it means
for there to be inflation
for there to be no inflation month to
month
if
the the if gas is skyrocketing
and then it goes up from you know two
dollars to five dollars
and then it drops down to four dollars
fifty cents they will say inflation is
at zero
even though it's massively up oh my
because it went down just a little bit
just looking at a teeny little bit but
this administration plays with numbers
all the time i mean that
i'm sorry this administration plays with
numbers all the time and they they
really condescend to the american people
because they count on us to be enumerate
or not to know how to read a chart not
to notice i think that's why
legacy media is kind of losing
hemorrhaging viewers and alternative
media is is booming and that's why
censorship is so important because they
have to try and stop that but but i do
have to wonder man does it really matter
i think the democrats maybe you know i'm
imagining they're all like sitting
around the consultants and like the dnc
or whatever and they're like you know
we've tried really hard to convince half
this country why don't we just convince
the stupid people
right that's so much easier and you
don't need to spend as much money
so now they're doing things that to us
it's like brazen
inflation is at zero what are you
talking about it's calculated on a
yearly basis how many people right now
are going inflation to zero uh actually
inflation is zero you're wrong here's
axios they said it's zero and you're
like uh
how do you how do you even even
negotiate or argue or compromise with
that i feel like it's just a desperate
move right we're getting so close to
midterm elections that they're like
we're not going to win everybody so
we've just got to get a couple here to
try and try and ease our way into a
victory i said november was gonna be fun
october is gonna be fun it's gonna be
crazy like okay so we've been swatted uh
now nine times since january and plus
we've had other security issues you this
group has been swatted yeah nine times
swat
teams come sorry i was not telling you
that before you got came on the show i
thought it was like a metaphor a figure
of speech no no no yeah yeah so so um
after the first like i think two or
three times
it was no longer like
multi-jurisdictional armed groups coming
into the house the first time it
happened it was bad like guns dropped
what had you done
we had marjory taylor it's a media
company they build walls around
paramount because people obsess with
media it's too accessible right right so
uh
we we we've we've had all of those
issues and i'm like yeah guys
he thought it was crazy wait till
october
right before isn't it quite traumatic to
be swatted one time let alone multiple
times the first time
you know they actually came guns drawn
and well tim was on air we were we were
on air and the cops like come to the
door and i'm like what is going on and
they're like they're like come out i'm
like i'm coming how are you doing in my
house you know what i mean good lord but
after that they would come and do a
sweep and then apologize and now they're
harassing you
well not the police the police are
instructed to come for every call i see
so people are threatening you and they
come to protect you people call the
police and then make a fake thing like i
am you know i am a crazy person
and so the cops are like okay wasn't
there just a twitch streamer who got
shot during this the streamer was
swatted and they got shot during shot
yeah hold on look it up but no there was
a there was a uh two guys who were
like fighting
online on like call of duty and then one
guy said here's my address do something
it was a fake address and when the cut
so the guy swatted the address when the
cops showed up the resident had no idea
what was going on opened his door walked
out with his gun and the cops shot him
yeah so so anyway i don't wanna i don't
wanna harp on too much of that stuff my
point is just that as we head into
october and november with the midterms
coming up you are going to see the
craziest
balls to the wall shenanigans
all over the country and uh october
surprises if you think there's just
going to be one no no you're wrong it's
going to be just everywhere it's like
photos are going to come out like you're
mentioning weird photos there's like
they're claiming now that alex jones
sent nudes to of his wife to ride your
stone or something like that like all of
the weirdest things you can ever imagine
they're going to throw everything at the
wall and hope it's i'm wait i'm looking
at the deep fix get ready for deep fakes
i think that did you see that biden
video where his eyes were open the whole
time and they're pure dark black circles
looked like a deep fake i'm not a fake
it looked like a deep fake i couldn't
tell but it didn't what do you mean it
didn't blank he talked about that real
low voice it was really weird i think
they just gave him up the world of deep
fakes is now be prepared do not believe
what you see at face value unless it's
coming at you charging you and it's a
bear and i i think they just gave joe
biden a bunch of uppers like i i'm
having a hard time believing he's like
listen here
and so the point where it's not that i
disbelieve what i see i just don't
believe it and that could be very
dangerous if it's an emergency like if
the boy has cried wolf many times and
now you're here naomi wolfe
hello welcome
do you have faith in the republic
generally in the american republic do
you have faith of its survival oh god
that's such a difficult question are you
you really want the answer
i think that we are at serious risk of
devolving into civil war
hey
i agree you stole tim's life yeah you're
gonna steal tim slogan there's like they
say in the chat they're like every time
tim says civil war drink what steps
would you talk about oh forgive me if
i'm echoing you and i did not realize no
we agree what how much you guys have in
common
to advise a circumvention of that what
would you
what are some gifts you would impart
these are my gifts um
social media and digital platforms uh
you know can be very empowering but
they're also a way to surveil and manage
human communications as we've discussed
there's
we're messaged that the things people do
together are like low tech and second
rate compared to digital tools but in
fact it's incredibly sophisticated a
room full of people talking to each
other or an auditorium full of people
with a speaker talking to a giant group
or a protest or a march with a bunch of
human beings um talking and sharing or a
movement where people are singing and
marching and praying together
so i would say to everyone the best
thing you can do is
get off your screens and get into rooms
with other humans and have fellowship
with them and feed them and be fed by
them and fall in love with them and you
know disclose your heart to them because
it's only those revolutions that really
are peaceful and survive and it's also a
very sophisticated way to communicate
information because hard to hack the
human brain yet it's hard to hack a room
where people are having a cocktail party
or a potluck or praying together or
singing together um and and we've
forgotten that we can gather like look
at what happened
in this in this country before digital
technology you used to have whistle
stops where people would talk to a
thousand people at once or you know all
the great movements the women's movement
the labor movement the civil rights
movement the abolition movement these
happen in person in real life so
my great blessing to all of you even if
it feels weird if you've been on screens
your whole life is to you know leave the
screens behind for a lot of time and
fall in love with other human beings
we've got a project we're working on
we're going to be opening up a physical
location
where we're going to have gaming uh so
we'll we'll have like a magic gathering
d d we'll have card games we'll have
board games we'll have coffee probably
maybe sandwiches or something like that
we'll have skating stuff as well
but the plan is with this space saturday
mornings uh we're going to do saturday
morning cartoons
where the idea is
you don't really have saturday morning
cartoons anymore because everything's
vod on demand digital but when i was
younger we'd wake up on saturday and
watch the cartoons so we can have
families come you bring your kids to
hang out and watch good family content
that is approved by the families none of
this weird stuff they're making for kids
there will be like a breakfast buffet
and parents will get to interact with
each other and the idea that i was
having was there's a lot of people that
don't go to church church does provide
some kind of something similar it
provides community so what can we do to
bring more people
hey come hang out saturday morning
something to do with the family we're
gonna have pancakes we're gonna have
waffles eggs sausage bacon some some
vegan and vegetarian options coffee milk
orange juice the kids will watch
cartoons everybody will eat we'll learn
from each other meet each other and
we'll hang out that's what you got to do
beautiful i love it i love it and
when people actually encounter each
other they realize there's nothing to
fear you know overwhelmingly you know
people will meet who are think they're
across a political divide and they'll
have a conversation and realize like
you're not a weirdo you're not a monster
our kids are playing together it's i
kind of like it when someone gets heated
and then you still listen to them and
you're still kind of even more bonded
afterwards right because you chose to
listen to them yeah like shut them down
before they got too angry gorgeous yeah
i love it my my best learning has come
from talking to people i think i'm going
to completely disagree with i don't know
why people are so scared of it it's so
exciting to hear what someone has to say
who totally sees the world in an
oppositional way to one's own thoughts
like how exciting is that it's you learn
so much yeah we used to chat roulette
and i'd come up on people from china and
talk to these chinese people i don't
know if they're behind the iron curtain
yeah roulette you just hit
like roulette and then you randomly
roulette with another sometimes it's
like you know a little bit pornographic
sometimes it's someone else go on there
that's a bad idea yeah i haven't done a
chat roulette in a while but great
functionality and it was i would like to
hear from them now i want to know what
they're experiencing from the chinese
point of view it's important that we
they won't be able to tell you the truth
if they're based in china but you should
stay in contact with them i should add
to that beautiful scene of people having
pancakes or having potluck or talking to
each other we also need to know where
our food is coming from i just my
husband i just bought a quarter of a cow
from a local
local farmer now we have to freeze her
but i expect um leading up to november
uh shortages in food
cyber attacks um uh power grid outages
uh all kinds of things to destabilize
and scare people and we need to be able
to defend our homes it's another reason
to know your neighbors right
your the internet community that you
build yourself can be great but no one
is going to come help you if let's say a
tree falls on your house or absolutely
you know you need something in the
middle of the night right you need to
know and invest in the people who are
physically around you because ultimately
they control or they influence the
environment you're in and that is more
important than the environment you build
for yourself online because that is
contrived yes i would add to that um
there's so much nonsense about gender
right which i did not intend
i didn't do it didn't mean it okay sure
right i really didn't
i was never that kind of feminist um but
we we need men you know we need women we
need men we need people of all genders
obviously but
when things fall apart and i thoroughly
expect institutions will fall apart um
you know grids will fall apart there's
going to be chaos leading up to november
and after that's what they want clearly
we need men as well as women but you
think in the next few months we're going
to see this stuff like food shortages
grids we're seeing them i predicted this
i predicted food shortages in in
starting in probably january of this
year and it was a time of great
abundance and we hadn't had empty
shelves and now we have food shortages
you know we you know there people are
going to be cold they're cold in they're
planning on people being cold in europe
because the supply lines the fuel prices
are through the roof i i periodically
will do shout outs for
safeandreadymeals.com
that is not literally a shout out but i
do want to mention it because i often
bring up
i was mocked by many on the left for
promoting emergency food supplies
they they they i i it's confusing to me
why why would they not be like cool you
want to be prepared have a good time
well that's the crazy thing so it's a
right-wing
thing to to think ahead to think about
your future people think it's
fear-mongering and he's trying to make
money off of scaring people but dude
he's a realist what is the downside it's
like having a condom if you're sexually
active right because you have some food
in your in your in your basement brand
water but that's the crate i'm like as a
first aid kit like prepping yeah exactly
exactly bro it's like yesterday it's
like you put in your closet there's a
huge class thing here right like upper
middle class people have first aid kits
so that's okay but once you get into
freeze-dried meals you know somehow
people like us don't have freeze-dried
hamburger helpers same thing with
lentils dried lentils man yeah right
right
that's pretty good i gotta make ian
makes a mean lentil stew i'm gonna do it
mmm
have they come around like does the left
you know see the point of ready meals
they they like this guy i knew like a
friend of mine started making fun of me
and he was like oh look there's a loser
cause he was like trying to earn points
on the internet by bragging on me and
i'm like dude
my whole thing is like why would you
need emergency food uh because there was
a flood recently that was really bad and
it shut the roads down and people had
trouble getting food and it's not
perishable so if your fridge goes out or
whatever you have a set amount of food
that'll last you two weeks or whatever
just same as you'd have a first aid kit
or a jug of water
but they they think it's just
it's anti-tribal it's outside of their
tribe
so anyone but look i literally don't
care man right when when i have the food
i'm gonna i got chickens
yeah i saw they're all those chickens
make food for me beautiful yeah they eat
bugs they'd feed too but you know if we
wanted to we could do the the bug thing
which you do is you put wood down and
then every morning you move the wood and
the bugs all run on the chickens look at
look at what we were taught to mock
right i'm looking back at 30 years of
liberal mockery that i internalized you
mock survival you mock masculinity you
mock you know the idea that someone's a
woman and a mother not to criticize any
other genders or
sexualities you mock religion you mock
uh you know tradition you mock history
and who wants that our adversaries want
that and and now i look at like you know
the influence their influencers that
that our adversaries send to skew people
like your friend and to to say to them
hey it's really stupid that your friend
has ready meals well who does that whom
does that serve people want to drive us
into the ground and have us hungry and
disempowered it serves them because when
when everything does fall apart these
people are going to rush to the city
center get on their knees and say save
us exactly they're going to say oh the
quarantine camp has food come on in yeah
i got a vision last night i was walking
like on horseback riding by people that
had been devastated by starvation just
looking at me as i'm riding by like you
see in the movie where the noble goes
through the village that's been torched
and they're just like looking at the
people and the people don't even have
energy to grab at the horse they're just
like laying there and the horror that of
the person that's never seen it face to
face
that just struck me like lightning last
night it was terrifying i feel like
there's a segment of culture that tells
you and i don't want to be too mean to
the liberals but i do think it's sort of
uh a more left left-leaning perspective
that says like you should live for the
now and you should be self-indulgent and
you should think about this whereas a
lot of conservative people who are
brought up in more conservative homes
are taught like you should plan for the
future and that involves everything from
saving money like tithing to your church
is something that a lot of conservative
parents teach their children but also
like think about if you want to have
kids in the future and how that will
affect you whereas there's a different
segment of culture that is like
it's all
it doesn't matter you just have to do
what feels good in the moment we have to
be self-indulgent we have to think um in
terms of immediate pleasure in turn and
not in long term
happiness and that's i think the same
segment that says like why would you buy
meals to be prepared like being prepared
is not an immediate thing being prepared
is something forward thinking it's that
rental society people are like i don't
want to get locked into an area so i'm
going to keep renting i don't want it
i don't want to commit to a community
that i would have to invest in and get
to know my neighbors i want to be able
to be transient and have uh the idea
that i'm always free because i can pick
up and move at any time but ultimately
i'm detached and i'm lonely right it is
a sort of freedom like to have all your
all your music digitally and on spotify
you have to carry around your cds which
are 50 pounds but if the power goes out
that's like you're you you had all that
rental that's not there well i mean if
the power said you can't play cds either
right yeah and spotlight's gonna take
out the songs that are not correct
anymore that have words we're not
supposed to say
yeah there you go that's forever i got i
got some vinyl i have like
15 some good classic rock good smashing
i think an element of what you were
saying as well as um
we on the left are trained to trust the
government and not give it a message of
self-help i'm sorry about that it's too
sad i don't like traffic i know i don't
but but what why like punk rock man like
i know when i was like i was like don't
trust the people
i know now it's really funny you know so
i when i was younger i listened to the
offspring they're like my favorite band
so uh i'm a little kid my mom played
folk stuff and three dog night whatever
and it's cool then all the kids in
neighborhood were listening to rap and
hip hop but then some other friends of
mine were like listen to the offspring
and then i was like oh cool you know
it's pop punk it's not you know not
nearly the same
but they're supposed to be a punk band
and they kicked out their drummer
because he didn't get vaccinated you're
kidding me yeah they fired him after 14
years because he couldn't get it he had
his doctor recommended against it over a
risk took of guillain-barre syndrome
that they believe he had and so he was
like the doctor says no and they're like
you're out and they're they were like
look you're not gonna be able to play
these venues they have the mandates
and it's just crazy to me because i'm
lying they didn't resist at all they
didn't they didn't put up a fight at all
and not even that right if it were me
and i said we're going to go to a venue
and
i mean i got to be honest if it were me
i'd be alike then i don't do the show
and i'll tell each and every one of my
fans if he doesn't come i don't come
because imagine if like imagine it it
was the 50s and this band was going to
play a venue and their drummer was a
black guy and they were like we don't
allow you know your drummer he's black
they'd be like well i guess we have to
fire you no i'd be like dude no way then
we don't go to your venue exactly right
but but anyway
it's like where's the anti-establishment
punk rock stuff they're like well sorry
guy you're fired here's the best part
one they could have just said we will
not abandon you dude we understand your
medical issue the doctor is recommending
you don't get it this puts us in a bind
we want to play shows we're gonna get
another drummer to tour with us but
you're we're here ready and willing to
work with you for all the other stuff
we're not gonna we're not gonna leave
you behind they could also have rehired
him once the mandates were removed from
these events they didn't do that they
didn't do that either football yeah so
uh pete pete paradis his name he's uh
he's been playing drums for us he's an
amazing person i am uh oh you hired him
well he's he's doing a bunch of jumps
for a bunch of projects but i absolutely
i'm like dude it would be an honor and a
prisoner so good right i believe it yeah
we just filmed a music video with him
yeah and uh it was he's just he's so
good majestic this is a true story i
mean how is it different from from ella
fitzgerald how is it different from
african-american artists who were not
allowed to sing at carnegie hall it's
exactly the same and i want to stress
this to people because i know they're
going to be like oh you can get the
vision his doctor said no
uh circle like to to to um
go after any potential arguments they
might have
when when if if you are unable to due to
a medical condition
so you get barred from you you're fired
from your job and barred entry like
imagine if there was a business that was
a venue and they said no epileptics
because we can't be responsible for you
it's like dude that's not okay man like
we should be accommodating to people so
like i agree with that that's a that's a
liberal position these people don't hold
any of these values they're they're like
whatever the machine says we don't want
to fight back we don't want to be in the
way well this was definitely one of the
most shocking i did follow the money in
the bodies of others and uh vast sums
are going to i don't know if it went to
this band but vast sums are going to
influencers all the way down to college
level i mean this foia of the cdc shows
that they're thanking the social media
groups for enlisting college influencers
in
you know their their goals of censorship
and directing salesmen for
pharmaceutical companies
exactly
sorry and even to churches and
synagogues and little social groups i
mean tiny dance troupes in the bronx
they got money to go along with covet
education coveted norms including this
kind of messaging did you see we talked
about yesterday the cn there's a cnbc
article that said
it was like pharmaceutical no no
investor investment firms goldman sachs
i think we're saying hey curing diseases
is like not a good long-term revenue
prospect so
and it's like confirming everything as i
remember the left was very much like we
don't trust big pharma because they
don't cure diseases they treat symptoms
so they can make more money and keep you
as a subscriber and now they're outright
just writing these articles and the left
is like marching in lockstep along with
the big things do you understand because
i don't understand this this is like
pure hypnosis it's a cult it's a cult
it's a culture and they're like if you
support trump you're an occult i'm like
bro no i think you're in the cult yeah
like the people who uh trump has has his
his cult you know very diehard people
but like where are they are they on are
they on tv
are they are they in in like where are
they there's a handful of politicians i
would say are die hard trump but for the
most part it's like there's libertarians
there's disaffected liberals and there's
conservatives they don't they don't
agree on everything but they just think
you're in a cult so it's like not even
about trump well i'm i'm meeting a lot
of conservatives and libertarians who
aren't particularly supportive of
president trump but who are horrified
and homeless former liberals like myself
who are simply horrified at what's
coming over the hill from the biden
administration and these allies and you
know other sort of aligned world
economic forum puppets all over the
world like nicole and boris johnson and
so on and
so i think it's kind of beyond left and
right at this point right yeah it's more
economic for me the federal reserve
tariff it bothers me it doesn't terrify
it just bothers me that we've passively
allowed a private company to run our
economy for 120 years and knock
you know
depressions it's insane it's moronic and
we need to we need to investigate the
federal reserve we need to audit the
federal reserve and if there's any
malfeasance repeal the federal reserve
act and take control over monetary
supply back we're going to need to do a
currency recall it's the only way we're
going to devastate america's experience
as the global currency that's inevitable
it's happening whether we want it to or
not right now we've already seen russia
and china building bricks and these
other their economy yeah
uh and it's either we do it ourselves
like ripping the band-aid off digging
open the scab and getting in there with
a bristle and some soap to cut out the
black
rot or it's gonna kill us by poisoning
our blood system so ron paul maybe
you gotta turn a sound currency but dig
it open man if you if you get black
stuff under your skin you gotta cut it
open and dig it out i mean that's you
gotta take control of your body
the united states is our body that's
intense
i had to do that once i was riding my
bike down a hill and i had a basketball
in my arm and i and the basketball came
out of my arm so i flailed and my foot
got caught in my front spoke i went
flying over skidded across the gravel
and all this embedded gravel in my hand
so i went home with got some nail
clippers and just cut all the skin open
all right
all right and it healed like completely
back to normal within like three days
it's not just human body is crazy we've
also got the swift payment system you've
got the i've been a week you've got
international yeah the bank of
international settlements in switzerland
it's a big
it's not a worldwide
uh cartel but it's it's a big one
australia england united states
did they boot russia off swift did they
do that or no yeah they did aren't you
guys saying two different things you're
saying go back to sound money right and
you're saying get rid of the dollar no
no he's saying the federal reserve
because the federal reserve notes are
there yeah we don't actually use dollars
right now we use federal reserve
promissory notes they lend us pro they
lend the american government a
promissory note and then we
they say okay now you pay you have to
pay us back this noted interest and
that's why all your dollars actually say
federal reserve note on it because it's
like private property it's a really easy
way to explain to people there's five
people sitting here right now
imagine we were all trading amongst each
other something of value but one person
was allowed to make the the money they
wouldn't have to do any work they would
just be like i'm gonna write myself like
i'm gonna write right here that i have
five dollars and then here you go give
me your stuff i think what we could do
is issue a currency recall so you say we
have two years every human on earth can
give us the we'll say the american
government your dollars and we'll return
you a u.s
uh
crypto token or something on a
blockchain and then there's going to be
a diminishing return you're going to
lose 20 of whatever you give us you're
supportive of digital currency if it's
on a blockchain and uh it's transparent
yes if it's just a central bank currency
where they can just make as many as they
want no mommy has such a like stressed
look on her what's gonna happen is we're
gonna have to keep creating new
blockchains with new tokens as we but
here's the spam the issue with digital
currencies is
it's all trackable totally everything
you do forever will be public it's a
plus and a minus no it's a it's a minus
i mean cash is key for sure tracking
every transaction that person is i don't
advocate busting up localities that want
to do their their local you know we
could have valence shells of of tokens
and policies i'll say this
you can
you know put uh
have a bitcoin
and then have a physical representation
that you can trade so no one knows which
hands it exchanged the value was just
stored in oh yeah
so if you have like a cold a cold wallet
or something and it's like got one
bitcoin on it
it doesn't actually move on the
blockchain if you hand the physical
drive to someone and they bounce it
around so that's possible yeah if you
could print something like in on just a
daily printer like on a piece of like
graphene paper that has like a code in
in it like a circuit in there that has
the data of the token on it that'd be
cool or i mean to put it simply people
could open a crypto bank where they hold
100 bitcoin and then
issue this represents one bitcoin but
they never do fractional reserve banking
it's just this is always redeemable for
us for a bitcoin and then anyone can
trade amongst themselves that's the way
money originally was it was it was a
silver certificate so when people order
certificates turn their us dollars back
in they're going to lose a 20 of their
money but the wealthier you are the more
you're going to lose the more money you
give back the more of a percent is going
to be taken out because we can't we have
to we have to deflate our economy
you can't we can't live with this amount
of amount of worthless dollars in the
system right now i am hearing that from
a lot of people including highly placed
kind of hedge fund insiders that the
amount of money sloshing around that is
imaginary is
terribly dangerous i was looking at like
the history of currency recalls and
they're not normally very
help peaceful for people no
brutal so if we could do it if we could
do it i mean the thing is
we could do we could do it peacefully
yeah uh well peaceful is kind of a
general term like what that means you
might have to you know people might
suffer but we could do it without
instigating a war
all right we're gonna go to super chats
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel and share the show with your
friends we're gonna have that members
only show coming up for you at 11 p.m
and this one's going to be really good
spicy it's going to be about the
government and malfeasance and issues
that youtube is done too happy with but
we'll leave it at that and we'll read
some of your super chats now all right
let's see moon phaser says i'm worried
they trick trump into a war with china i
hope they don't fool him into anything
crazy if he becomes president 2024.
i don't know who they is you mean like
the establishment or the political class
or whatever i don't know i don't think
they'd be able to
trump is very much like america first
borders no war so
we'll see
all right dalmar says register to vote
two months minimum before day good point
day of id pen paper hand count national
state and local holiday absentee for
deployed military only all over excuses
or reasons oh well don't care yeah
everybody should make sure right now
you're registered to vote right now yeah
and then uh call uh what do you say five
of your friends and make sure they're
right sure to vote
tell your buddies like hey everybody and
that they're going to vote right that's
the other part well the best thing is
i'm like when it comes to election day
what you do is you invite all your
friends out to get pizza and beer and
then while you're driving you stop at
the voting location of their area and
then be like we're going to run in real
quick make sure we vote and then we're
going to go and and have wings and beer
and that's what we got to do it i i also
believe that uh um election day should
be a national holiday yeah and there
should be one day as the constitution
prescribes
intuitive coder says i like ian
[Laughter]
ruler of star says i also like ian
what's happening what's happening
that's great
all right we will grab i want to try and
find some uh some some good
some good super checks those last two
sucked
this just kidding yeah people liking ian
what do you what do you know what
joe spinella says tim you need to get
former irs agent joseph bannister as
well as author of income tax shattering
the myth dave champion on your show both
found there is no law making 99 no
lawmaking 99 of americans
dave alone hasn't filed for 24 years uh
i thought that's i do not believe that's
true
there was a very famous case about ed
and elaine brown where a bunch of
government agents came and arrested them
because they did not pay their taxes so
pretty sure that's not true yeah no
yeah
all right
what's uh let's grab some good questions
i always want to make sure we're
getting the good ones
all right eve welcome says please have
naomi go through the ten steps free
societies are shut down end of america
was a warning ignored
yeah it is is it really really long and
verbose or is it easy enough to go
through i'm actually googling my article
but i will i will skip over some um so
you start with a terrifying internal and
external threat as i mentioned it can be
a real threat but hyped and exaggerated
like the global war on terror or a virus
that
most people came from somewhere with
exactly
um
then you get into creating a thug cast
then you get into creating a place
outside the rule of law where prisoners
are held like at your point about
january 6th prisoners or guantanamo in
the case of global war on terror
you create a surveillance society
so people are spying on people or you
know digital technology is tracking
people and then i'll skip ahead you know
five six seven eight you start to
criminalize speech as you and i were
discussing you start to target um key
individuals uh in the culture which
we're also seeing um you know being
people take being taken out you start to
create an environment in which people
can't tell truth from lies there's so
much confusion so much lying
misinformation in the news people just
kind of give up and then step 10 is
to suspend the rule of law martial law
which most people don't even know we're
at right now uh many of your maybe your
clued in viewers do know but most
americans literally don't know that
president biden extended emergency law
in april because of the situation in
iran i kid you not like who's writing
his material but he keeps extending it
in an open-ended way and state by state
many states 28 states are still under
emergency law and extending it like new
york state my
tyrannical governor hocal extended
emergency law every 30 days so we're
we're there we're at step 10.
wow all right shadow cloud says only a
few years ago she was pro-abortion up
until birth that is not true
that is not true not true that is
categorically not true and i really
wonder why that's being um attributed to
me
because you're a feminist well let's
hear more they say her crowder interview
has uh has her stance changed
i literally strongly object to
something i didn't say being attributed
to me
i think that people should check their
sources before they claim that people
believe things they don't believe and i
refer everybody to an essay i wrote
called our bodies our souls in 1995
which is much syndicated and you can
find it anywhere in which i explain my
incredible unhappiness about the moral
angst and difficulties that arise with
abortion after the first trimester i do
believe that for women to have any
autonomy at all we have to control our
reproduction for the first trimester the
first 40 days in my tradition i'm jewish
you know there are other traditions that
allow for abortions in the first 40 days
it's not good it's not happy it's always
a failure
of something
but i do not believe in abortion after
the first trimester i don't yeah so i
was noticing this is something that i
had wanted to ask you about in 1995 you
were saying that we need to call
abortion exactly what it is which is
murder and it does no one any service to
call anything other than that do you
think that's a fair representation do
you still think that
um can you repeat your your summary i
just want to make sure i i don't know
hopefully i've got the summary right but
my understanding was that you were
saying it does no one any service to
call it anything other than what it is
which is simply murder i think you're
probably referring to after the first
time uh trimester uh i said it's it's
death it's death of a being i don't i
don't know that i use the word murder
i'd have to check but but i definitely
the gist of that article was
we
pro-choice feminists are lying when we
use phrases like a clump of cells
um and that and that it
has no moral integrity to say a
four-month fetus that we want is all oh
look at the sonogram isn't it cute here
let's frame the sonogram and a form of
fetus that we don't want is just
something to be you know flushed away or
done away with and
that i also i love feminists for life i
love them because they point out that
feminism for 100 years before the second
wave of feminism um opposed abortion and
saw women's need for abortion it's
always an act of desperation right who
wants no one wants to have an abortion
no one i know has ever wanted
like you want an abortion rather than a
baby sometimes in your life
unfortunately not you but many women i
know but
but
people aren't like oh how wonderful i'm
having an abortion but
i think that there is a push to make it
like that i don't think people are like
i want to get pregnant so i can have an
abortion
yeah
maybe she meant it maybe but i don't
think she really was like seeking it out
she never did she might have said it she
didn't do it it's tribal cultism where
they want to be a part of the of the
cult i mean some little kids want to
smash ants just to watch them suffer so
maybe they also want to divorce you from
the consequences of what an abortion is
really like i remember i mean teen vogue
famously did this article where they
were like what to get your friend when
she has an abortion and it's like movies
so she has something to watch and
planned parenthood enamel pins for her
backpack because they were able to
provide her this important service i
mean this is a publication which has
become very uh
left slightly radical
theoretically is targeted at teenagers
what's a teenager 13 to 18 19 maybe at
the most i mean
they're
encouraging young women to think of this
choice as sort of this weird quirky
milestone like you treat it the same way
when your friend goes through a bad
breakup bring her some ice cream and a
good movie i totally know what you're
talking about because the culture was
even there when i was a teenager and in
high school i remember that it was like
oh you went to planned parenthood oh no
you need gossip and and plan parenthood
like i love them in a lot of ways
because they help protect young women
from getting pregnant that is really
important but there was this kind of
trivializing of the abortion or almost
glamorizing of the trip to planned
parenthood to have it done and the drama
and so on and i've seen that i mean i've
seen uh you know
websites aimed at saying that parents
who want to know about their teenage
girls being pregnant or choosing
abortion to have a say in it are
coercive and oppressive patriarchs and
and and really there's this
glamorization of of
taking over the teenager and and you
know getting her through this in a kind
of cozy cute way and it's that's
disgusting but
what i just wanted to share because it
was so new to me when i first heard
about it is that feminists for life have
what they call a seamless web of life
philosophy they oppose
capital punishment and they oppose
abortion but they make the case that if
we really had and i wrote a substance
about this recently if we really had a
pro-woman society
we wouldn't treat abortion the way we do
now we would have all kinds of support
for young women who got pregnant the
women who most often have abortions are
in their 20s right so what might we have
we would have maybe
places they could go you know to bring
their baby to term we would have easy
adoption we would have free
contraception we would have all kinds of
real choices that don't drive young
women into just this one choice and they
would be supported and and you know good
nutrition and all the things that they
need and we don't do that right now it's
just either you know exploit them as
child bearers or exploit them as
people to abort and then kind of
trivialize have you seen all the
pregnancy centers that were attacked
vandalized or firebombed terrible it's
terrible it's terrible and i'm sorry i'm
going to go further and say i think
young people are having what i can only
call i used to think people who talked
like this were crazy right wingers but i
do think there's a kind of evil kind of
almost satanic satanic stance ah
discourse everybody drinks she said it
yeah
do you say satanic no i'm just kidding
i'm making up for you
yeah people call it black pill like if
people are
really if they have etched in that they
were overpopulated that kind of myth has
been propagated whether or not it's real
or fake myth it's a myth um it's a story
that we've been telling ourselves that
there's just this idea of like burn it
all you know whatever if it's too much
then it's too much i give up kind of
thing which you could call evil or
satanic alex jones says demons demonic
and he doesn't mean uh to a certain
degree doesn't mean literally these
people are demons he means figuratively
these are like demonic individuals well
it's demonic to say a a six-month-old
fetus is is nothing that's demonic i
completely agree like your your your
position on it it
really i think exemplifies my family and
how how we viewed it i was always told
growing up it's never a good thing it's
always bad but you know we don't like
the idea of within a certain period like
the government coming in but my family
urban liberals were like at a certain
point like you're just killing a baby
yeah seriously these days you know
they're they're cheering for it it's
terrifying so when we had on this
progressive guy progressive guy in your
seat me here and christian a catholic
conservative seamus coughlin who wants
abortion banned in all circumstances
across the board and he wasn't even
arguing it was me and the progressive
guy arguing and he was calling me right
wing and i'm like bro i'm pro-choice
like i'm like traditional pro-choice and
i think you've crossed the line but he
was like the women can choose at any
point to terminate the baby even at nine
months but what is this gonna do like
why not then kill neonates you know why
not then
have you seen governor northam in
virginia totally i've seen their two
state bills i've seen them i thought
again i thought the right-wing crazies
were making it up but then i read the
bills and i have this wonderful um
editor
kate malgozza who's in her 20s who did a
breakdown of one of these bills they let
you let the baby die both in washington
state and in virginia a month
virginia i don't know if they passed it
or i think they tried to i think it
failed saucy take the baby and make it
comfortable and then have a converted or
like d form or whatever but bro if the
baby is resuscitated and alive there is
no circumstance you know i i can
understand a circumstance where it's
like we can we can we can we can help it
live for five minutes and it's gonna die
and that's probably cruel it's another
thing to out to outline in law
a viable baby that can survive on its
own can be killed oh and it says that
the bills say that yeah
tried passing that nationally and
manchin was the one who blocked it
but but who did that i mean people have
to remember their history nazis did that
the nazis did that from 1930 to 1933
before they were in power they did
what's happening to especially people
your age or your age i should say they
they progressively eroded the idea that
there was any sanctity to life and you
know you start with the um mentally ill
they're you know useless eaters they're
life and worthy of life then you move on
to the okay it's 1938 we go after the
jews okay it's you know 1942 we feed
them into ovens this is a progression
and i mean cannibalism like people are
telling me oh yeah there's this
cannibalism thing and pop culture i'm
like come on new york times and then
there it is yeah or you know there are
these satanic images in pop culture like
come on really i mean you guys are crazy
christians whatever but there it is you
know and so this is really happening and
and i think it's intentional because
effort goes into drafting those bills
you have to pay lawyers to draft those
bills why are they drafting those bills
no one's clamoring there's no lobby
saying i want to let you know newborn
month olds die this is absolutely i
believe coming from our enemies to
degrade
reference the useless class like it
they're really they're not useless yeah
to be fair though malik does demand
child sex well all right that's a good
point yeah let's let's read some more
super chats we got sergeant kirk who
says private citizens can and should be
able to have nuclear weapons we already
live in a world where they do who makes
the nuclear weapons for the government
private corporations true facts
private individuals so when you have an
ffl you can actually someone sent told
me this is a form you can fill out for
nuclear weapons because
it is private corporations that make
them all
government doesn't make them
halliburton and boeing and northrop
grumman and all that they make the
warheads they make the missiles but they
don't make them attached they let the
government do the
is that
i don't know it's like building the
receiver but not building the gun
all right andrew reese says naomi
curious if your opinion of camille
paglia has changed over time any new
conversations or responses to each
other's work since the 90s you speak of
marxist you speak of marxist influence
similar to her
huh interesting um well i never
i don't think i started the name calling
in the 90s but um i mean this is ancient
history but yeah camille paglia was a
protege of harold bloom who sexually
molested me essentially was when i was
under an undergraduate and i think it's
interesting that she kind of hounded me
the first decade of my career um and
harold bloom was such a force behind her
kind of astronomical ascent
from nowhere
but i'm always willing to engage with
anyone uh i haven't had any approaches
from her for many years um and she never
to your point about debate i once ran
into her
physically and i'd never met her before
she'd just been sniping at me for you
know a long time and calling me names
and i said you know we should really
have an
open public discussion an open debate a
constructive debate and she sort of
scurried away did she wave her hands and
go no no i'm not going to do that not no
she just kind of fled like a you know
little marmoset
all right
and let's grab some good super chats
let's see what we got
mr devil man says i don't protest i just
want to be left alone
i am trained to fight wars you never
want to see a war but if there is one
i'll be one of the many bringing on the
war machine
that's what we hear a lot the people who
are actually trained in war are the ones
begging it not to happen yeah
civil war whatever what's uh so you
mentioned potential civil war i talk
about it quite a bit
um four years ago with the street
fighting i was reading these articles
talking about the prospect of civil war
and seeing this i said it feels like
we're on track for one
when do you think if it were to happen
like what's your timeline
well let me stress that i
civil war is
terrible i don't want it um i don't want
anyone to take this out of context out
there in internet land and media land
and misunderstand me um but i i see it
happening already i mean civil wars
failed states are really interesting
like
or states where there's no rule of law
like i was in sierra leone in 2006
and there was no rule of law that's why
i'm so scared of a state of no rule of
law but there were militias and so we're
kind of there right like when auntie for
whoever they were i think they were
heavily infiltrated because the left
just isn't that organized but um when
people are burning
whole neighborhoods in cities that's
already a form of civil war and when
people are um you know when there's
eminent domain when things are being
taken from people as we're seeing with
the dutch farmers or the truckers or the
people who supported the truckers that's
already an aspect of civil war the war
is being waged already against the
people of north america the people of
the west i mean this is the argument of
my book the bodies of others so
it it's not always violence um in the
street although there is plenty of
violence in the street it's also um
theft and restrictions um you know this
whole idea in lockdown is that there
were places you couldn't go that's part
of civil war right where some people
claim rights to certain territories and
other people aren't allowed to go there
um and that restrictions only happen to
populations that are about to have their
assets stolen from them like in the
warsaw ghetto or native americans on
reservations so we're in a civil war
already um the whole defund the police
movement i think is part of um waging
war against the american people are
instigating a civil war because
the more crime there is as we've said
the the the more people have to kind of
turn to themselves to defend themselves
um and and you know this bill
86 000 new irs agents they keep trying
to create militias remember step two is
you create a thud cast you create a
black water a militia black shirts brown
shirts thugs that are not accountable
you know up and down the chain of
command in an organized structure of the
rule of law and and this administration
and these world economic forum puppets
around the world are creating those like
those guys dressed in black who are
beating up the truckers in canada are
the same guys dressed in black who are
beating up protesters in france um and
and they they look like mercenaries
they're working they're not like local
police they were anti-mandate protesters
outside of a hospital and anti-shut up
and started beating them
and it's like so the guys outside of
post-government intervention and antifa
anti-fascists support government
intervention funny
all right slain hope says ian clearly
didn't learn a thing from uncle ben's
death cutting criminals loose has
consequences the left is already doing
this how is that working
uh i don't know who uncle ben is really
so uh so here's what happened ian
spider-man
was uh he was at a wrestling match
and he was he was denied the money he
was supposed to win because the promoter
was like yeah what are you gonna do
about it and then he was like
then this guy comes in and steals the
money and runs off and the promoter goes
hey stop that guy and then spider-man's
all like oh you know what are you gonna
do about her something like that and
then he goes outside and the dude who
stole the money is trying to get away
and try stealing a car and then shoots
the man inside who happens to be
spider-man's uncle ben you see
so the moral of the story was with great
power comes great responsibility i see
but this is a crime and process
that uncle ben got killed during a crime
and process yeah okay but spider-man
could have stopped him he could have
stopped the criminal but he chose not to
out of a personal vendetta he chose to
let the criminal go the criminal i don't
i don't wanna go he's like no i don't
advocate ignoring future crime that's
not what i'm talking about if someone
wants to commit a crime after we do a
great pardon then they're going to jail
or they're going to face wait a minute
wait a minute hold on hold on i got to
stop slain you're wrong
it was revealed in spider-man 3 that it
was actually sandman that killed uncle
ben
and it was an accident and spider-man
forgave him
retconned for your
generation but the point was
spider-man ultimately forgave sandman
who apologized saying he didn't mean to
do it it was an accident and spider-man
had to learn to let that pain go
exactly when someone has wronged you and
you still forgive them
yeah who's the christian here i don't
know if any of these analogies actually
work or make sense i think it's just
funny to talk about spider-man
all right raymond g stanley jr says
chair cast irl rocked 40 000 congruent
viewers concurrent viewers
um
so when we we had a credible threat it
was it like two months ago or something
yeah just about we were forced to
evacuate
and this we just left the show on
as we were kept outside by the police
and
dogs in the room cam yeah so we did the
wide cam and it was 40 000 people stayed
and watched an empty room for three
hours
that's kind of cool yeah
it's cool it's kind of cool it was kind
of lame that we had to leave you know
but
stream but you know
yeah find the silver lining to these
constant threats
i'm really sorry you guys are going
through this yeah yeah but it is what it
is it's civil war right no it's that
we're we're we're running an
entertainment company
this is that's why they build walls
around the entertainment companies
because people want to go there and say
hi and be part of it i remember america
i remember i remember america when
journalists and entertainers were not
um in you know in fear of their of their
lives but since the dawn of internet
video
tim has no overhead he started with a
camera in his in his bedroom that's what
people are getting way more famous
living room living room living room
living room i i i digress uh they have
way more fame than they have money right
now for security so people are
in this just bizarre reality of exposure
that has never existed in the past
you know there was something special
about that first room i set up i would
take a gopro for and i'd put it on top
of my monitor and just press record yeah
and then i would just talk for like 10
minutes and that was it and it was like
and that slowly got longer and longer
but those are special days i advocate
building a walled compound i think it
makes a lot of sense when you run an
entertainment company you just need to
build like barriers i married my
bodyguard i'm not going to judge you for
caring about
security and bodyguard i love it
what i think everybody needs is a
40-foot wall
thick concrete from sea to shining sea
protecting their home
and uh maybe some auto defense turrets
yes maybe specifically maybe
remember when they claimed trump wanted
a moat with alligators on the border
sure like cool let's do it you gotta get
crocodiles though or cry i don't know
what these like crocodiles are a little
nasty
all right
joseph mcfarland says federal reserve
notes are already one-tenth of a u.s
note taken back at only nine hundred
percent of face value
restore a constitutional currency
deflate by ten percent of true original
value freeze market prices for six
months
i don't know if it's possible raising
the market's pretty pretty pretty
communist but i don't know we're in
desperate times right now
all right
do for use as says i decided to join
reddit to combat the mind virus my lord
it's way worse than i imagined and here
i thought fb and twitter were bad
i believe that reddit is bots
do you know about uh dead internet
theory yeah the idea is that
sometime around donald trump's election
multiple agencies internet companies
realized like hey letting people have
free speech on these platforms is really
bad for global infrastructure
so now the internet is overwhelmingly
just bots
simulating public opinion i believe that
i mean from my own experience i believe
that and most people are banned a
handful of influential people are
allowed to post everyone has robots wow
robots yep
wasn't this a huge part of the twitter
deal with elon musk they couldn't say
how many bots they had yeah well they
claimed they did and then he says they
didn't so
bear in mind says the irs has a 600 000
bounty on anyone that can crack the
crypto xmr aka monero it's an amazing
endorsement is that true
600 000 i don't think that's enough
money to be honest
like they'd have to offer way more to
crack the encryption on on a
cryptocurrency you know that that's a
crazy undertaking
yeah 625 000 reward for cracking monero
let's go into cryptocurrency365.com
i just don't see that being possible
well i don't know maybe quantum
computing
up to 600.50 what does that mean it
means one dollar
like oh congratulations you destroyed
this now monero's doing a big upgrade
the next couple weeks i've heard oh good
for them
all right uh
seth hauser says did you not vote for
biden and the democrats in 2020. i did
you did
i did
what was your what was your reasoning
then when you voted for biden especially
considering everything you've said now
well i told you my strong feelings about
how president trump talked about
sexual assault um
but that wasn't even the main thing
though personally it was a hurdle i
couldn't overcome
the main thing also was the climate and
the environment
and
i thought that the biden administration
would be real liberals i
i thought they would um protect the
environment i thought they would ensure
you know some
rights of women to reproductive access
which i do believe in in the first
trimester i thought that they would
protect
our core institutions and i
did not realize and my husband told me
right because he knows china um he was
in military intelligence for 12 years
and he's like you guys are going to open
the door to a massive subversion of this
country by your enemies and i was like
this is crazy and he was 100 correct
would you vote for trump in 2024
i'm supposed to stay nonpartisan so i
can't answer that i will say
that i would never i i'm no longer a
registered democrat i'm an independent i
think the democrats have like
100 years of um cleaning up and
apologizing and breast beating and
internal cleansing to do and they need
to be investigated for pharah
conflicts because they're taking money
from our enemies at an intense scale um
but i i do think a dream team
if i can say this in a non-partisan way
is actually um desantis and christie
gnome
no yeah i think she's great too um i'm a
big fan of desantis he's so good yeah
he's amazing um
you know we'll see we'll see that you
know there's a little bit of back and
forth trump firing everybody is really
appealing to me the schedule was
scheduled f stuff he's trying to do but
uh ron desantis just
removed that that woke prosecutor so
he's showing a willingness to do it as
well we'll see he's a courageous guy
yeah
and she's she's amazing she did not shut
down she didn't shut down when i was in
south dakota and he did briefly so she's
really the bravest of all governors when
i was in that right
sorry they had a parade for her
like people were like yeah
yeah when i was there it felt like
america used to feel yeah wow people are
not traumatizing she is so extremely uh
patriotic that i think it would be
amazing to see her on a national stage i
can't speak to all of her policies but i
do think that she captures a nostalgic
spirit of american politics that we just
don't have anymore right on all right
everybody if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and head over to
timcast.com we're going to have a
members only uncensored show for you
coming up at 11 pm this one's going to
be going to be really good and uh really
crazy government intervention and
censorship stuff like seriously dark
stuff so check that out timcast.com you
can follow us at tim cast irl you can
follow me personally at timcast naomi do
you want to shout anything out
um
to follow me yeah follow you or read
your book or please well i'm i'm so
thoroughly censored indeed platform that
please go to
allseasonspress.com and buy my book the
bodies of others the new authoritarians
covet 19 and the war against the human
there's the cover um and read it and
share it with your friends if you're
moved by it um and also as i mentioned
daily clout dot io where you can uh send
any state or federal bill through social
media and you can also um we've got a
facebook competitor uh called campaigns
that is surveillance free and uh and
censorship free cool right now yeah
i'm hannah claire brimlow you can follow
me on at instagram hannah claire.b you
can also check me out on this super cool
news site you guys may probably haven't
heard of it it's called timcast.com
uh click on the read tab you can see
articles from me adrian norman cassandra
fairbanks a ton of cool people i highly
recommend you check it every single day
that's fall median crossland.net get
through any social media i got if you
want to get in touch through that naomi
great to see you and i want to put your
mind at ease about the climate if i can
we are entering uh an era where we'll be
pulling the carbon dioxide out of the
atmosphere converting it into graphene
through like some sort of catalyst like
a magnesium catalyst or palladium gold
copper something like that and methane
as well will convert the methane into
carbon dioxide and then into graphene
which is this uh building material i'm
not sure if you're too familiar with it
but i i would recommend he's obsessed
he's a totally yeah
this is a relief to hear ian yeah they
can pull it right out of the smoke stack
it'll encourage pulling more coal out of
the ground hitting it with lasers to
turn it into a cleaner burn than
recapturing the carbon and reusing it i
think it'll bring a lot of people
together the industrialists and the uh
the eco
the eco-fanatics like myself i hope so
catch you later bye everyone yeah if you
like more of graffian's ideas you can
follow him me and hannah claire brimello
over on pop culture crisis with crisis
which is every weekday from about three
to about 5 p.m depending on what we get
into mary's out of town next week so
it's going to be really interesting
we're going to shake it up with some new
co-hosts and have some fun over there
you guys can follow me on twitter
mines.com at sour patch lids as well as
sour patch lids dot me we will see you
all over at timcast.com thanks for
hanging out bye guys
you